monument historique de plus de mille ans
d'âge l'église saint-martin de
sartrouville va se refaire une beauté
une convention était signée mercredi 20
octobre entre la mairie de sartrouville
et la fondation du patrimoine est l'acte
le lancement officiel d'une collecte
publique pour la reconstruction du
clocher un clocher particulier qui
nécessite d'être repris intégralement
c'est le seul clocher octogonal
d'île de france qui a été construit à
l'époque comme ça et donc il ya un
problème de joint entre l'ensemble des
pierres qui constitue là le clocher donc
il va falloir le démonter entièrement et
le remonter à l'identique parce que
c'est un travail important dont un
budget important et la fondation du
patrimoine est à nos côtés on s'engage à
partir de cette convention à mettre les
moyens de la fondation pour faciliter
cette collecte la rendent optimale faire
en sorte que y ait un maximum
viré de dons qui arrivent pour permettre
la meilleure réflexion possible face à
un problème de sécurité le coup d'envoi
de deux ans de travaux sera donné début
novembre une restauration répartis en
trois phases la première va durer un an
c'est les travaux sur la partie est de
montres de l'élise avec notamment la
flèche la reconstruction de la flèche à
partir du tambour ensuite la phase 2
c'est donc le reste des façades avec la
restauration complète des façades des
contreforts mais également de la
couverture et de la chair compte les
quatre derniers mois de travaux c'est la
phase 3 chez les travaux intérieurs avec
du remplacement de deux parcs est
attaqué par la vrillette et le
renforcement et l'extension la tribune
en vue de l'au-delà cette finale dans le
plus gros des travaux la reconstruction
de la flèche à l'identique historique
vous faisant déposer toutes les pierres
de la flèche et on va garder les pierres
qui sont sur les plus les plus saines en
fait certaines pierres qui sont
détériorées qui sont moins de 10 cm
d'épaisseur donc pour celle là on vient
les remplacer par de nouvelles pierres
montant des travaux 3 5 millions d'euros